chaos here they brought traffic to a
standstill within minutes and they've
based themselves on the eastern docks
roundabout it blocks access to the port
of dover as well as access to the a2
towards london we've seen a massive
buildup of lorries here anger and
frustration amongst drivers mounting
we've seen some confronts some
confrontations between them and the
protesters as well and there is a really
big police presence here as well
now some of the protesters are glued
down there's two on a tanker in the
traffic as well
and it's all to make a stand to the
government they're demanding that the
government do more to make homes more
energy efficient to tackle climate
change it's the first demonstration
insulate britain has put on since the
government got an injunction against
them for protesting on the m25 but that
injunction is only in place for the m25
it has no effect here down in dover
now so far more than 200 act of it more
than 200 arrests have taken place in the
fortnight they've been protesting but
that's not put them off at all they say
that they're more scared of climate
change than any government injunction
and they say that they will continue
doing this until the government takes
action okay for now thanks so much
indeed thanks a lot
my extended knowledge of the law is
essential law for journalists but if
you're going to take out an injunction
for the m25 to stop them doing that you
think would you not make it a bit wider
than that because would they not just go
somewhere i don't know anyway let me
know what you think